la fermeture des écoles au printemps et
maintenant la rentrée affectent les
jeunes de différentes façons j'avais
quand même hâte de commencer l'école
pour une fois c'est rare quand on sait d
confiné ont fait pas avoir tous les
contacts physiques qu'on avait
l'habitude d'avoir comme moi je suis
quelqu'un qui aime beaucoup faire des
câlins la quarantaine était difficile
nous deux on fait de la danse
moi j'ai arrêté un peu parce que sam
comme n'ayant dans le fait d'être
musulman pour 1 200 à peu près 15 16 ans
aussi dur psychologiquement au clsc de
saint michel une équipe en santé mentale
s'occupe des jeunes c'est la porte
d'entrée pour obtenir des services avant
la pandémie ce qui était très prévalant
c'était vraiment les troubles anxieux
mélo nous on voit les les symptômes
dépressifs augmenté chez les gens depuis
que la courbe des cas de co vide s'est
aplatie celle des demandes de
consultations auprès des intervenants
grains les soit son corps soit
présentement sont plus intenses
qu'habituellement donc les gens ont fort
probablement attendu plus longtemps à
m'en faire la demande pour les
chercheurs en santé mentale l'année 2020
devient laboratoire en avril mais on
s'est dit mon dieu faut voir qu'est-ce
que la non fréquentation scolaire qui
était généralisé au québec à ce moment
là aura comme effet chez les enfants et
les adolescents
l'étude grandir pendant la pandémie
propose un questionnaire en ligne un
pour les plus petits et un autre pour
les adolescents on cible tous les jeunes
qui fréquentent une école primaire où
une école secondaire au québec donc
c'est de 6 à 17 ans comme je disais
qu'ils lisent à un problème
d'apprentissage ou pas qu'ils soient
privés ou publics peu importe et dans
toutes les régions du québec toutes ces
variables vont nous indique est vraiment
le portrait de ces jeunes l'ocs ont vécu
cette année l'offre particulière un peu
plus de 400 jeunes ont déjà répondu mais
on espère enjoindre davantage d'ici la
fin octobre
côté social ça a été vraiment dur parce
que tout seul personne n'aime ça
vraiment cette recherche pourrait servir
de guide pour baliser les interventions
auprès des jeunes qui en ont besoin
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal